Let's go ahead and
get started, you guys.
OK, so before we
begin, I just want
a brief note about the quiz.
So you should get the quiz
back tomorrow in recitation.
The mean and median on the
quiz were 69 out of 100,
so look for it tomorrow.
And there should be solutions
post it also tomorrow.
Does anybody or member
with standard deviation
was on the quiz?
OK, thanks.
OK, so the topic
for today, we're
going to continue
talking about networking.
And just to recap where
we left off last time,
I wanted to review a few of the
best effort network properties.
So you remember at
the end of lecture
last time we talked about
this notion of a best effort
network.
And we said that
these packet switch
networks like the Internet are
typically best effort, which
means that there are
certain things in particular
that they don't guarantee.
So one property of
best effort networks
is that they're
subject to delays.
So these are delays due to
the propagation of messages
down our wire, the time
it takes for the messages
to propagate along the pipe.
Remember we talked about
that analogy last time?
Time to transmit the
message, so transmission time
is sort of the amount
of time it takes
proportional to the
length of the message
and the bit rate of the link.
And then, there is
additional delays
that are introduced
by these properties
that we talked about at
the end of the lecture
last time such as queuing.
So the fact that remember we
said that these networks are
congested and the load is
somewhat unpredictable.
And because the load of the
network is unpredictable,
that necessarily
means that there
are going to be queues
in between the links
on our network.
And then finally,
additional sorts
of delay that we
talked about, but also
can be an issue as
the processing delay.
So this is the delay
incurred by sort
of the overhead of processing
messages between switches,
for example, in our network.
OK, so other interesting
properties of best effort
networks, they incur some loss.
OK, so there are
going to be messages
that are corrupted as they are
transmitted down these links.
There are going to be losses
that are caused by congestions.
Remember we talked about how
one of the only responses,
oftentimes the best
response to congestion
is simply to drop packets
to reduce overload.
And there are sometimes
going to be failures
that are going to be switches
within the network that
will sometimes simply
cease to function.
And of course
you're going to lose
the data when that happens.
And there can be
reordering of packets.
So you didn't talk
much about this.
But it's fairly
sort of obvious idea
that suppose an application has
two different messages, right?
Well if you think about the
way that those messages may
be routed along different
paths through the network.
And we'll talk about this
more when we talk about how
routing works next time.
But because they can be
routed along different paths,
there's no guarantee that the
messages, because message one
was sent before message two,
that message one actually
arrives before message
two at whatever
endpoint you're sending to.
And finally, there
can be duplication.
And duplication is often a
side effect of techniques
that we'll again talk
about next time for dealing
with this issue of loss.
So if you have lost packets,
somewhere in the network
you may want to try and
retransmit those packets.
And because you're
retransmitting things,
you're sending things
multiple times.
There can be places
in the network
where you actually see
two copies of a message.
So these best effort
networks have a number
of sort of properties that make
using them somewhat complex.
And what we're going to
talk about over the next two
or three lectures
basically are ways
of mitigating the complexity
of these best effort networks,
of making the interface
that these best effort
networks provide to
applications a little bit
more usable in the sense that
we're going to try and find
ways to reduce the
effects of things
like loss and reordering are
to make it so that applications
don't necessarily need to
be aware of those things.
So in order to start
getting at sort
of dealing with
complexity, we're
going to talk today about
this notion of layering.
So -- So when we talked
generically about systems
earlier in the class, we
said that a standard way that
we're going to deal with
complexity is by introducing
modularity.
And the specific
kind of modularity
that is widely used within
networks is layering.
And that's what we're going
to talk about most of the time
today.
The other way that we
typically deal with,
another common way of
dealing with complexity
with the networks is
by using protocols.
And a protocol is
really just a set
of rules for how two
machines on the network
do communicate with each other.
So, for example,
a protocol might
say that if I want
to tell you about,
if I want to send a message
to you that I will put
this certain bit of information
at the beginning of it,
I'll put some address
information at the beginning
of that message.
And the message will be no more
than a certain number of bytes
long.
And I'll put that
message on the wire,
and then part of
the protocol is also
that you will send an
acknowledgment back
to me that tells me that
you in fact got the message.
So these protocols
are very well defined
sets of rules about
how communication
is supposed to happen.
These protocols
are going to help
us to deal with
complexity because they
are going to tell us
what we expect to have
happen within the network.
And when things don't
follow the protocols,
then that's going
to be an indication
that something went wrong,
and that we should therefore
try and recover from it.
So, for example, if
we lose a packet,
the protocol is
going to allow us
to detect that a packet
was lost and request
that that be retransmitted.
We'll talk much more
about protocols next time,
but it's sort of
worth bearing in mind
that almost at any
time, two things
are communicating within
a network that are
using one of these protocols.
And a protocol is
just a set of rules.
OK so I want to just
quickly give you
this list of five questions.
We're going to come back to
this list of five questions
a little bit later.
But these are sort
of five key questions
that we need to
sort of figure out
how we're going to actually
resolve in networks.
And the first question is, how
do we multiplex conversations
on a network?
When we talked about
this last time,
we have these two different
alternatives, time division
multiplexing, which we said
was used in telephone networks.
And we talked about
packet switching
as a way in which we can
have multiple people sharing
a network.
But there is a bunch
of other questions
that we haven't
really answered yet.
And this is what
we're going to get
at over the next few lectures.
So how do we transmit
bits on a link?
How do we actually,
given a wire,
how do we actually modulate
that wire in the right way
to transmit the message that
we want to transmit down it?
How do we forward
packets via switches?
So we sort of said that
there are these switches,
and that along any
communication path,
there may be sort of
multiple communication hops
that have to be taken
through multiple switches.
But we haven't yet talked
about what is actually
going on inside those switches.
So we are going to look
in particular at what's
going on inside
switches in the Internet
and see how that works.
Then there's this
question about,
how do we actually make
communication reliable?
So we said that one of the
limitations of a best effort
networks is that, well,
it introduces loss,
and it can reorder packets.
Applications
oftentimes don't want
to have their packets
reordered or dropped, right,
because they're trying to
actually exchange information
with each other.
So we'd like to understand
what kinds of techniques
we can use that
can systematically
allow us to avoid, or to
make communication reliable.
And then, finally, how
do we manage congestion?
So we said that one of
the fundamental problems
with these packet
switch networks
is that the amount
of load may be
unpredictable in the network.
So the question that we
need to ask, then, is, OK,
how are we going to
manage this congestion?
What are we going to do in
response to congestion in order
to sort of minimize
the effect that it has
on the applications that are
trying to run on the network.
OK, so we'll come back to
these questions in a minute,
and as we talk about what the
layers of the network stack
are, we'll sort of see how
these different questions
fit in to these different
parts of the network stack.
But what I want to
do now is really
turn to this issue of layering.
OK, so in order to understand
a little bit about why there
might be wires within
a network, or a
why there might be layers
within a network, excuse me,
let's look at a very
simple kind of a network.
So suppose we have some
client, a client, C, OK,
who has a number of
different connections
to the outside world
available to it.
And, it can connect each
of those connections
go, say, for example,
to some switch which
may in turn connect to
another switch which may in
turn connect to some N host S,
server S, that the client is
trying to communicate with, OK?
So, suppose C is trying
to send a message to S.
Let's think a little bit about
how this might actually work.
So we have the application,
which is perhaps running on C.
And, it might try
and send a message
by calling some
routine send S message.
OK, so it says send to endpoint
S this message that I have.
So let's think about
how we might actually
go about implementing this.
So one way that you might
have the application send
a message to S is
that you might have
this sort of the application
might understand everything
about what the whole network
topology looks like, right?
So, it might understand, know
about all the different links
that are available to
it, and with each one
of these different links, it
may understand what the topology
of devices that are out there.
So if I have a connection
to the Internet, that
would mean that I have to
understand all of the machines
that are connected to
me via the Internet,
right, so I have this
list of a million hosts,
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE] every
client, and I sort of just
scan down this list
of a million machines
that I can connect
to until I find S.
And then I send a message
out over the next link
or something, right?
So this sounds very
complicated because it
forces the application
to understand
the sort of entire functionality
of the network underneath it,
how the network is
connected, and how
the nodes talk to each other.
So that doesn't seem
like a very good idea.
Right, instead we'd like
to application simply
to be able to just
send its message out.
And we would like some
lower layer service
to take care of the
details of figuring out
where to send the message next.
So, in networks, we talk
about that sort of service
that runs underneath
the application, that's
in charge of figuring out what
the next sort of connection,
the next top to use
within the network,
we call that the
network layer, OK?
So, I'm going to
abbreviate as NET.
And so, what the network
layer, for example, suppose
this client had three
connections available to it.
It has a modem connection.
It has a WiFi connection.
And maybe it has an
Ethernet connection.
What the network
layer is going to do
is it's going to
look at this name, S,
that the client has specified.
And it's going to try and
decide which one of these links
is the next link to use in order
to forward the message on to S.
OK, so it's just going
to make a decision
from amongst the
available connections.
So, it's going to basically
pick the next link, OK?
And if this is the
Internet, you're
going to have these switches
or these routers that
may have links to a
bunch of other networks.
And so in the Internet,
the network layer
runs actually on all of the
routers within the Internet,
and is making these
decisions about how
to forward packet after packet.
So we'll see again in the
next lecture and in recitation
how the Internet actually
does packet forwarding.
But so we said there
is this network layer.
But we have this thing that's
picking the next link to send
the message out over, right?
But we don't necessarily
want that thing
to have to understand the
details of how you actually
communicate over each of the
available physical connections,
right?
So suppose that the
only thing that was here
was this network layer.
And the network layer
had to understand
how to communicate over
Ethernet and WiFi and the modem.
Right, well then
the network layer
is going to be very complicated
because, of course, sending
messages out over
a wireless radio
is very different than sending
messages out over an Ethernet.
So what we have
is one layer that
sits underneath the network
layer, which we typically
call the link layer.
And the link layer is
responsible for managing
the physical connection for
the transmission of data
from a long just
one of these wires.
It's the thing that
actually moves bits
from C to whatever the next
top within the network is, OK?
So, these are these two layers.
You notice now, I've
left this hole here.
You might be wondering
what goes into that hole.
So what we said is
so the network layer
is responsible for
picking the links.
But remember that what we
talked about so far in this best
effort network abstraction
is sort of affairs
all these problems, decent sort
of with delays, reordering,
duplication, and so on.
And it might be that
neither of these layers
really is responsible for
dealing with those problems.
What we said is,
what we want, to be
able to provide an
abstraction for applications
where some of these problems
with the best effort networks
are hidden from the network.
OK, so typically
networks introduce
a third layer,
which in this class
we call the end-to-end
layer that's
in charge of addressing
these kinds of issues.
The end-to-end layer may seem
a little bit fuzzy, the details
of it when we talk about it
because the end-to-end layer
can do lots of different things
for different applications.
OK, so some applications
may be concerned about,
for example, the possibility
of messages being lost, right,
whereas other
applications may not
be as concerned about
messages being lost,
but may be very
concerned about delay.
And we'll see as we
talk to the class
that delay and loss trade
off with each other which
makes sense.
If I lose a message and
I have to retransmit it,
that's going to increase
the delay on the network.
But, so it's possible to sort
of trade these things off
for each other.
So the end-to-end
layer is the thing
that's responsible for trying
to make application environment
sort of more pleasant
for the application.
And that can mean dealing
with trying to eliminate loss
or trying to minimize
delay, for example.
We'll talk about different
kinds of end-to-end layers
in just a few lectures.
OK, so these are
kind of the three.
So we're going to decompose
our network into these three
layers.
And in order to sort illustrate
this to you a little better,
what I want to do
is just walk you
through a simple example
of how the letters might
look in the Internet with
a simple web application.
And I'm going to use
some of that terminology
from the Internet
here, and we're
going to return to some of
this terminology, introduced
its older more
carefully in recitation.
But I'll try and explain
it as much as we go.
So suppose we have a
laptop, say my laptop here,
that wants to connect to
a Web server, MIT.edu.
And, the way that
the Web works is it
uses a protocol
called HTTP, which
is used for making requests
for specific webpages,
and for returning the
results of those webpages.
So these are typically
called requests and responses
in the HTTP specification.
Now, if you look at, so this
is sort of from the user's
perspective; the
application is a browser
that knows about
the http protocol,
or a Web server that knows
about the HTTP protocol.
And it's running on these
two remote machines.
Underneath each of
these things, of course,
there is a set of layers.
And each of these things
has layers underneath it.
And these layers correspond
to these three things
we just talked about, the
end-to-end layer, the network
layer, and the link layer.
So one thing you
may notice here is
that the link layer is different
between these two things.
So the laptop is perhaps
communicating over WiFi,
and the Web server
is communicating
over the Ethernet.
But otherwise these two
things have the same;
their Ethernet layer and their
network layer are TCP and IP.
So, TCP is going to be in
charge of basically providing
this reliable
abstraction for us.
We're not going to
talk about it anymore
today, except to
say that, that it
makes communication reliable.
We'll see how it
does that later.
What IP is responsible for is
choosing the sort of next top
to make along each connection
of the way, each connection
within the Internet.
So, IP is the protocol
that runs the Internet.
And, you may have
seen IP addresses.
So, IP addresses are
the sort of names
for the endpoints
in the Internet,
and takes an IP
address and basically
gives you this
next link that you
should use in order to
transmit a message out over it.
OK, so suppose that
the browser generates
a request for some page.
What it's going to do
is it's going to call
send on the end-to-end layer.
OK, so I've just written this
as E to E send to make it clear
that this is a send
request to the ETE layer.
And it's going to
pass some message.
In this case, the
message is simply
going to be the contents
of this request.
And it's going to
specify the underlying
protocol that it should use
as well as the destination
address.
So this address is one of
these Internet addresses and IP
address followed
by this colon 80.
So, what colon 80
does is it identifies
what's called a port number.
And it identifies
the application
we're running on
the remote server
that we want to
communicate with.
So, typically Web
servers run on port.
Now, you say they run
on port number 80.
That just means that the
TCP layer on the other side
knows how to communicate,
knows that the Web
server on the other end is
connected on this port number
80.
So it gives us a
way to communicate,
to identify applications that
are running on the remote host.
So now what happens is this
request is going to be,
the TCP layer is going to
take this request, which
I've shown in blue,
and it's going
to attach what are called
headers and trailers to it.
So these headers and
trailers are the information
that TCP needs, the TCP
layer on the other side
is going to need in order
to deliver this message
to the application.
So in particular,
this thing is going
to contain this port number
that we already mentioned.
So this is going to be used
on the other end in order
to send the message
to the Web server.
It's also going to have
a sequence number, which
as we will see
later, we're going
to use in order to, for
example, reporter in order
to detect reordered messages
or detect lost messages.
OK, so the TCP layer now is just
going to repeat the same thing.
It's just going to
take this packet,
and it's going to call
some request, say,
NetSend [SP?] on the IP layer
that sits underneath it.
And again, it's going to
specify the set of data
that it built up, which
we called a segment.
So that's what SEG is, which was
the purple and the blue blocks.
And it's going to pass
that on to the IP header
using this NetSend
message to the IP layer.
And it's going to tell the
IP layer what IP address it
wants to send this message to.
Now, the IP layer is going
to take this message,
and it's going to
put the header on it.
So IP doesn't use a
trailer, although it could,
in principle, use a trailer.
And this IP header is
going to sort of just
contain the IP address
of the next hop,
or of the destination.
OK, now the IP layer is going
to do exactly what we said.
The IP layer is
our network layer
so it's going to do exactly
what we said it does before.
It's going to look at
all the available links
that it has to it, and it's
going to send this message out
over one of those
links that it believes
is the correct next
top in forwarding.
So it's going to call link send.
It's going to pass
this packet on,
and it's going to specify
the name of the link
that it wants to use.
And it may have to specify
some address information,
for example, what I've shown
here is just [cool?] in one
just to say whatever machine
is one the wireless network
at wireless address number one.
So you guys saw sort of a
similar addressing scheme being
used in Ethernet last time.
You can sort of think
of that the same here.
So what happens now is of
course the same process.
The link layer attaches
its header and trailer.
So, I've called WH and WT for
WiFi header and WiFi trailer.
And now at this point we
called this thing a frame.
And this frame is now
ready to be delivered out
sort of along the next
top of the network.
So suppose that the
network layer identified
one particular switch
as the next destination
of this packet.
It's going to send this out
over the network to the WiFi
interface of this switch.
The switch is going to
receive this message.
What it's going to
do is it's going
to take the WiFi header
and the WiFi trailer,
and it's going to peel
them off of the message,
and it's going to pass the
message with just the network
header, no more WiFi header
on it up to the IP layer.
Now the IP layer now
has an exact copy
of the sort of message including
the IP header from the laptop.
And, so what the IP
header layer will do
is look at its IP
header labeled NH here,
and it'll decide what the next
appropriate hop to use, to send
this message out, it is.
So it's going to then
pick the next link
to send a message out over
and, say, in this case,
it decides to send the message
over an Ethernet connection.
The Ethernet connection is
going to receive the message.
It's going to attach its
header and its trailer to it.
And then it's going to send
it out to the next link, OK?
So this process just repeats.
The message gets sent
to the Ethernet link
on the other side.
The Ethernet link forwards
the message onto the IP layer.
The IP layer
decodes the message,
decides what the
next link to use is.
In this case, it decides
again to use an Ethernet link.
And it sends the message
out over the Ethernet.
Finally we get to MIT.edu.
And once we get to
MIT.edu, we just
start forwarding this
message up the layers, OK?
So, we do what are called
up-calls from the lower layers
to the higher layers,
notifying them
that a message has arrived.
So, the Ethernet layer peels
its headers off, sends them up
to the IP layer.
The IP layer peels
its headers off,
sends them up to the TCP layer.
Then remember, we
said the TCP layer,
so the TCP layer has
a port number that's
associated with it.
The port number is used to
identify the application that
should receive this message.
So, the TCP layer
pulls out the port
and sends it up to the
web server, which finally
receives our request, OK?
Now the Web server
does whatever it does.
It chews on this
request for a while,
and say, for example,
generates a webpage,
generates some HTML
that it's going
to send back to the client.
And now this process just
repeats all over again.
The MIT.edu sends
a message back down
to TCP identifying the
client as the endpoint
that it wants the
message to reach, OK?
So this is sort of the basic
way in which we use layering.
What I want to do is now kind
of step back and look at,
I sort of presented this
as a very quick example.
But what I want
to do is step back
and look at some of
the sort of rules
that we are following
as we use these layers,
and to sort of talk
about why we have
sort of constructivist
thing in the exact way
that we have constructed it.
So the first rule that
we are following here
is called encapsulation.
So what encapsulation
is, is it's simply
this way in which you notice
that when we send messages out,
each layer associated
its own header
and trailer with those
messages that were sent out.
And it didn't modify
anything about any
of this sort of data that wasn't
associated with the header
and trailer for that layer, OK?
So, encapsulation
says that each layer
may add or remove
depending on whether we're
sending a message down
or sending a message up.
Its own headers are trailers.
OK, but that layer doesn't
touch, doesn't look at or use
the payload from higher layers.
OK, so the link layer
doesn't look at anything
that the end to
end layer sends it.
It simply treats this
as a block of data
that it has to transmit, and
it doesn't understand anything
about what the contents
of that block of data are.
It doesn't assume anything
about the contents
of that block of data.
Similarly, the network layer
doesn't assume anything
about the contents
of the data that's
received from end to end layer.
And similarly, the
end to end layer
doesn't assume anything about
the format or the layout
of the data that's received
from the application layer, OK,
or from the application.
So what this layering
abstraction buys
us is that it allows
these things to sort
of coexist without any
understanding of what
the other layers do.
So in particular, it means that
we can, for example, change
something about the
format of the data
that the network layer sends.
And we continue to use
the same link layer.
OK, so I can send it out
over an Ethernet that's
not data that's been sort
of packaged up by IP, right?
It doesn't necessarily
have to be an IP packet
to send it out over Ethernet.
And so, this sort of
separation between the layers
is going to be really
critical for allowing
us to sort of
maintain and develop
new networking code over time.
And it also means
that the people
who provide the sort of
companies that build and sell
software and hardware that
works at these different layers
don't really have
to assume very much
about what the other layers
are going to provide, right?
So if I'm making
an Ethernet card,
I don't have to understand
anything about exactly what,
I hopefully won't have
to understand anything
about exactly what's sort
of going on up at the higher
levels of the network stack.
You have to be a little
bit careful, though,
because of course
the individual layers
do have some protocol that
there is some sort of API
that they're using to
interface with each other.
So, API is an application
programming interface.
You have some set of routines
that they call on each other.
So for example, I
showed in this example
up here that the
networking layer
is calling this
link send message
on the link layer below it.
So the link layer has to provide
this link send interface.
And similarly, there's
a comparable interface
when the link layer receives
a message that uses to send up
to the network layer.
OK, but basically
what this means
is that we can develop
the software that
runs at the different
layers in isolation
without having to worry
too much about what's
going on at the layers
above or below us.
OK, so --
Let's return back to
our set of questions
now and talk a little bit
about how these questions map
onto our three layers.
OK, so our first
question is, so we
said question one is, we've
sort of already addressed that.
But question two is, well, how
do we transmit bits on a link?
OK, so clearly that's going
to be handled by layer two,
OK, or by the link layer, sorry.
And, so the link
layer is the thing
that's going to be in
charge of actually pushing
the bits onto the link.
And none of the other layers
need to know about this.
Question three, OK, how do we
forward packets via switches?
Well, it seems that it's
pretty clearly what's
happening at the network layer.
OK, so the network
layer is the thing
that's deciding sort
of which packet,
what the next link that we
should use is within a switch.
OK, and now questions
four and five
are these questions about
this kind of our best network
properties.
How do we achieve
reliable communication?
How we manage congestion?
These are things that were
going to worry about at the end
to end layer.
OK, so just to sort of
illustrate a little bit more
about sort of how the
commercial, and how
these things are separated in
sort of a commercial world,
I thought I'd just show you the
slide that sort of illustrates
that there are lots of
different vendors, both hardware
and software, that run at each
one of these different layers.
So, for example, at
the end to end layer,
first there are clearly
a bunch of applications
that run up there.
And each of those
applications perhaps
has some different sort
of set of requirements
about how data is delivered.
And those
applications, typically
the sort of things
like the TCP protocol
are provided by, say, the
operating system vendor.
So Microsoft Windows provides
an implementation of TCP;
similarly Mac OS and
Linux also provide this.
At the network layer
now we have sort
of this huge variety of people
who are building these network
switches.
And these network
switches are the things
that have sort of
coded into them
the rules for how you should
forward messages around
on the Internet.
And so these are these companies
like Cisco and Alcatel,
in sort of these big companies
that hear mentioned in the news
all the time.
And then finally at the
sort of lowest layer,
there are these sorts
of link layer things.
And again, there are a number
of link layer technologies
like WiFi and Ethernet.
And those link
layer technologies
are different than
the technologies that
are used to actually
decide which
hop we should next use in
order to transmit data around
in the Internet.
OK, so if there's a big
diversity of applications.
And part of this
diversity of applications
is enabled by this
separation of the layers
because Microsoft
Windows doesn't really
have to know anything about
how the network layer works.
It simply passes
sort of messages
on for the network to transmit.
OK, so and the point
is that the vendors
are generally different at
each of these different layers.
OK, so given this sort
of high-level overview
of layering, what
we're now going
to do throughout the
next few lectures
is to pay some attention to how
each of the different layers
works.
So we're going to
start off talking
about this class
about the link layer.
And then we'll move
on to the network
and ends to end layers
in later lectures.
OK, so we've sort of seen
some of the things that
touched on some of the
things the link layer
needs to provide
at a high level.
But let's make a list and talk
about what these things are.
So the first thing clearly
that the link layer does
is manage the sort of
transmission of bits
along this physical wire.
OK, so there's going to
be some digital to analog
to digital conversion
that happens
in sort of as a part of using
any one of these links, OK?
And this is going to be one of
the main functions of the link
layer is it's
going to decide how
this sort of digital to
analog to digital conversion
is done, OK?
Another thing to link
layer does is framing.
And so, framing,
well you remember
we talked about
at the link layer,
we sometimes call for messages
that are transmitted around,
we call these things frames.
Framing is simply
separating the frames,
is deciding how we should
separate the frames that
are on the wire.
So it says, how
does the software
that's running at the link layer
decide that one frame has ended
and another frame has begun?
That's what framing is about.
And we'll talk about these
two issues briefly today.
The other kinds of things
that happen at the link
layer we're not going to talk
about as much about today.
One of them is channel access.
And so this is how
somebody who wants
to send a message actually
is able to physically use
the wire or the air that
it's transmitting out
of without interfering or
something on top of something
else who's transmitting
at the same time.
So you guys have read
the Ethernet paper,
and you saw one way
in which that's done
and Ethernet, which is basically
by listening for a carrier,
right, which is
called carrier sense,
and only when the
channel is not used,
there's not a
carrier on the wire,
does somebody try and send.
And then you use this notion
of collision detection
and Ethernet in order to
actually sort of detect
whether or not you are able
to successfully transmit
your message.
So these are the kinds
of things you worry about
in channel access.
Last time with
the phone network,
we talked about time
division multiplexing
as another way in which you
can sort of share access
to a physical wire.
You can carve it up into a
bunch of little units of time
and assign each sender
one unit of time.
OK, so now the last
link layer issue
which sometimes is
done in the link layer
is error detection
and correction.
And I don't want to
talk at all about really
how error detection or
correction works except
to say that some link layer is
included in some link layers
don't include it.
The idea here is suppose we
are transmitting a message out
over a wire.
Of course, there's
some probability
that that message
will become corrupted
or garbled it is being
transmitted, either because it
interferes with somebody
else who is transmitting
at the same time, or as
the message propagates,
it decays somewhat and we
can't decode it anymore.
So sometimes link layers
include a facility
for doing this error
detection and correction.
And error detection
and correction
is one of these things
that can sometimes
be included at the link layer,
and is very often included
at the end to end layer.
And so, as you read, the
reason I mention this
as being a part
of the link layer
is that as you read the end
arguments paper for recitation
next time, you
should sort of think
about how the end-to-end
argument relates
to whether error detection
and correction should
be within the link
layer or should
be within the end to end layer.
OK, so let's talk about
these sort of two issues
that I said we'll
address briefly here.
So the first issue
I want to talk about
is how the conversion
from digital
to analog to conversion works.
So -- So the way to think
about, suppose that we have some
sender which has some sequence
of bits, say, one, zero, one,
zero that they want to send
out over the radio channel.
So if you think
about what this is
going to look like in
terms of an analog signal,
they are of course are
many different ways you
could represent it.
But a simple way to
represent it might
be to say that this
is a digital line,
and we'll make the line high
when we are transmitting a one,
and we'll make the line low when
we're transmitting a zero, OK?
So we would send
this message out
as high followed by low followed
by high followed by low.
So this would be
one, zero, one, zero.
OK, you might ask
the question, OK,
how do we decide when to
sort of push the next bit out
on to the wire?
Well, typically
the way we do it is
we have some clock
signal that tells us
when the next bit
should be, we should
start sending the
next bit on the wire.
So we might have some protocol
that says something like,
every time there is a rising
edge in the clock signal,
we'll start transmitting
the next bit.
So, what does that mean?
So a rising edge --
OK, so suppose this is our
clock and this is our data.
And what I've just shown here is
that every time a clock signal
goes high, we start
sending in new bit.
OK, so every time we go from
low to high in the clock signal,
we start putting a
new bit on the wire.
So, now it's going to
happen is oftentimes
the way the network
connections are
connected is what's a
so-called serial connection.
So we have one wire that's
transmitting the data.
And we don't have
a separate wire
that includes the clock signal.
We just sort of transmit
the data out over the wire.
So if you were to
look at this data
as it comes down the
serial connection,
at the receiver, what it would
look like is something that
was sort of, it's not
going to look exactly
like these nice square
pulse was that we have here.
It's going to have
decayed somewhat.
So it might look
something like is
each of these nice square
waves might have sort of become
a somewhat decayed version
of their former selves, OK?
And now the question
we have is, OK,
how are we going to
decode this, right?
So we don't have access
to the original clock
signal that was used.
But we may know what
frequency, would
rate this data was encoded at.
So we may be able to generate
a comparable clock signal.
So suppose we generate
a clock signal that's
about the same frequency,
and then try and use
that to decode the message,
say, by looking again
at the rising edges.
If we're not
careful, we're going
to get something that's wrong.
So in this case, I transmitted
one, zero, one, zero,
but now I'm decoding
something that's
shifted from that somewhat.
So I'm decoding
zero, one, zero, one.
So, I've sort of become
offset because the two clock
signals aren't actually
identical, right?
Even though they're
at the same frequency,
they are not specifically lined
up with each other in time.
So we say that those
signals are out of phase.
So one signal is
essentially a time shifted
version of the other signal.
OK, and this time shifting
leads to these kinds of problems
where we don't properly decode
the message because we're not
sampling the channel at
the right point in time.
We're not looking at
the channel to see
whether it's high or low.
OK, so how are we
going to fix this?
It turns out that there's sort
of a simple and elegant way
that's often used to fix this.
And it's what's called a
phase lock loop or a PLL.
So a phase lock loop,
a very simple way
that you can implement a
phase lock loop is as follows.
So the idea here is
that what we want
to do is we want to figure
out, we want and make it
so that the receiver has
essentially a lined up version
of the transmitters clock.
So we need to figure
out how much we
need to shift the
receiver's clock in order
to make it line up with
the transmitter's clock.
And once we do that, then
hopefully we will properly
decode the message
instead of being shifted
when we decode the message.
So the idea with a phase lock
loop is kind of as follows.
Suppose we have our
signal like this.
A simple way to implement
a phase lock loop
is to take this signal
and to sample it
not once per clock, but some
multiple number of times
per clock period, OK?
We call this oversampling.
We might, say for
example, do eight times
oversampling on this.
OK, so what that means is if
we were perfectly lined up
in time on this
oversampled signal,
and we were encoding a one as
a high, and a zero as a low,
then what we would see if
we were perfectly lined up
is alternating sequences of
eight zeroes and eight ones,
right?
So, if instead we
start decoding this
and we see something
that's not quite that,
suppose we see three
ones followed by eight
zeroes followed by five ones.
OK, so we decode two bits worth
of information off the wire,
and we see that it's sort
of shifted in this way.
OK, that suggests that I
need to shift the signal
to the left some amount.
OK, and so this is exactly
what the phase lock loop does
is it observed the
signal as it's coming in,
and it computes
an amount that we
need to shift the signal in
one direction or the other.
OK, so if you wanted to make
a sort of schematic for how
a phase lock loop works, we have
our sender and the receiver.
The idea is simply as follows.
You have some data
at the sender,
and a clock at the sender.
Those go into some encoder box.
They are transmitted
out over a line
to the receiver, which
has a decoder box.
OK, but the decoder box
needs a clock signal
that's been lined up with the
sender's clock signal, OK?
So we're going to do is use
our phase lock loop to do that.
So the phase lock
loop is going to take
in the incoming signal as
well as the unaligned clock
from the local machine.
And it's going to input into
the decoder an aligned clock
signal.
OK, so basically
what's going to happen
is this PLL is going to be
able to reconstruct the clock
signal from the sender.
Of course, it takes a little
bit of time for the PLL
to reconstruct the clock signal.
So usually what we do is every
message that we transmit over
the link, we have some sort
of set of synchronization bits
at the beginning of it
that we use in order
to allow the phase
lock loop to lock in
to the phase of the
signals being transmitted.
And that preamble doesn't
carry any data bytes.
It's simply sort
of overhead that's
on every packet to guarantee
that the sender and receiver's
clock synchronize
with each other.
So there is one
last little detail
associated with phase lock loops
that you guys may have noticed.
So the issue is that
the signal that I've
shown being transmitted here
is a one, zero, one, zero, one,
zero signal, right?
But if you think about the
way that this phase lock
loop works, what the
phase lock loop does
is it looks for these transition
points in the signal, right?
So it looks for points
where the signal changes
from a one to a zero, right?
So suppose that instead
of transmitting one, zero,
I transmitted zero, zero, zero,
zero, zero, zero, zero, right?
Then the problem I'm
going to have is I'm
just going to have a very
long sequence of zeroes
even if I do this eight
times over sampling.
I'm still just going to have
a long sequence of zeroes,
and I'm not going to
know how much I need
to shift the signal, right?
I'm going to have
no way of computing
how much I need to
shift the signal.
So it turns out there's a very
simple and kind of elegant
solution to this called
Manchester encoding.
And the idea with Manchester
encoding is as follows.
It says will transmit
a zero as a transition
from a low to high, and
we'll transmit a one
as a transition from
a high to a low.
OK, so now if I transmit
a signal like one,
zero, one, if I transmit the
signal: zero, zero, zero,
it simply looks like this.
So, zero is a transition
from a low to high
followed by another transition
from a low to a high.
OK, so now this is zero,
zero, zero, zero, right?
And if I transmit the
signal, zero, one, zero,
this is a transition from
a low to a high followed
by a transition from a
high to a low followed
by a transition from
a low to a high, OK?
So now we have a way that we can
guarantee that every bit as it
least one transition in it.
And that's going to
allow our phase lock
loop to look into the
face of the signal that's
being transmitted.
Of course, the cost of
this is that we've now
doubled the number,
sort of, we've
doubled, every bit as a
transition in it, right?
So we sort of have the number
of bits that we can send over
the channel because
instead of a one
being simply a low, or a one
simply being a high and a zero
being a low, now everything
is both a high and a low.
So we have the amount
of data that we
can send on the channel.
But we've sort of
gotten this wind
that now we can have the
phase lock loop actually work.
And so turns out Manchester
encoding is actually
commonly used.
There are other encoding
schemes that you
can use that are sort of less
wasteful of channel bandwidth,
but operate on the
same principle,
trying to introduce extra
transitions when possible.
So this basically wraps up our
discussion of the link layer.
What we're going to
talk about next time,
are going to start talking about
how the network layer works.
And we're going to
basically talk about
how Internet routing
actually functions,
and how these routers
actually decide which
link they should use to
transmit the next message around
in the network.
So, that's it for this time,
and we'll see you on Wednesday.